하나 아셔야 될게 이게 쏟아진다
[음악]
이거 안녕하세요 피캐스트 진행을 맡은
김지 있니다 오늘은 저희 bsn 캡틴
김윤수 대표님과 함께합니다 아네
안녕하세요 저는 bsn 대표 김윤수
먼저 빌딩 시장에 관해서 한번
이야기를 나눠 볼까 하는데요 요즘
빌딩 시장은 좀 어떤가요 일단
작년보다는 좀 되게 괜찮아진 거
같아요네 작년 빌딩 시장이 사실 좋지
않았는데 작년 1분기만 해도 어 담보
대출로 빌리면 금리가 거의 한 6
7% 정도 됐거든요 근데네 요즘에는
한 4%대 잘 받으면 한 3% 대까지
나와서 올해 1월부터는 그래도 빌딩
계약이 꽤 있었던 거 같습니다 아네
그렇군요 거래가 점점 증가하는
추세라는 말씀이신 거죠네 그리고 이제
어찌됐든 하반기에 금리가 좀 더 내릴
내려갈 좀 이슈도 있긴 해가지고 아마
작년 하반기보다 뭐 좀 더 거래량이
늘어나지 않을까 이렇게 예상하고
있습니다 아네 감사합니다 어 또 최근
영상에서네 부실징후 기업이 던지는
매물들이 쏟아질 것이다라는 말씀을
하셨는데요 고객분들께서 그러시더라고요
강남에 금매 쏟아진다고 해서
기다리신다고 그러면 대표님께서 하신
말씀 네 밸류업 목적인 분들께도 좀
해당이 되는 부분일까요 일단 제가요
영상을 찍었는데 사실 막 쏟아질거다
이런 건 아니고 그냥 이제 개수가
많아질거다 뭐 요런 의미로 좀
봐주시면 될 거 같고 그리고 밸류업이
목적인 분들 이제 그때 사셨던 분들이
개발을 못하시거나 아무래도 뭐 건축비
상승이라는 뭐 대출 이잔 때문에
감당을 못해서 내놓는 매물들도 꽤
있을 것 같긴 하거든요 그래서 이렇게
밸류업이 목적인
분들한테도 좀 이런 기회가 올 거
같아요 그런 매들이 좀 더 많아질 거
같아요 하나 아셔야 될게 이게
쏟아진다 이거 사실 뭐야 되지 좀
썸네일을 좀 자극적으로 한 거고 그냥
좀 더 많아질거다네 이렇게 보시면 될
거 같습니다네
알겠습니다 그러면 건물 투자를 여러
번 해보신 분들도 계실 테지만 처음
해보신 분들도 분명 계실 텐데요음
내가 수익을 얻고자 투자를 하는 네
오히려 손해는 보지 않을까 좀
두려움이 크실 것 같아요네 그러면
건물 투자를 마음 먹으신 분들께
해드리고 싶은 말씀이 있을까요 지난
호환기 때죠 2020년
2021년도에는 몰사
올랐어요네 진짜 몰사 올라는
시장이었는데 지금 같은 경우에는 좀
확실한 거만 좀 오르는 시장으로
바뀌었어요 근데 그게 원래 맞았고네
그래서 만약에 지금 빌딩 산다 그러면
잘 팔리는 지역 사실 황금성 이 제일
중요하거든요 잘 아시겠지만 이게
매물이 좀 잘 안 팔려요 애매한 지역
가면 그래서 좀 전 제일 중요하게
생각하는게 잘 팔리는 지역에 좀 살라
그러거든요 그게 실패 확률도 되게 좀
줄어들고네 그리고 잘 팔리는 지역은
그만큼 수요가 많은 지역이다 보니까
그래도 가격이 계속 오른 곳이거든요
그래서 만약에 처음 빌딩 사고
싶다라고 하시면 수익률이나 뭐 임차
다 떠나서네 일단은 잘 팔리는 지역에
좀 사는 거를 좀 권합니다
아 입지가 중요하다는 말씀이신 거죠
그렇죠 그리고 입지란 플러스 그
입지에 잘 팔리는 금액대 아 그 예를
들어서 뭐
연남동이재용 네 그러면 다음엔 bsn
관한 질문으로 넘어가 보겠습니다 예
대표님께서는 해외 부동산 투자 부동산
잡지 발행 부동산 관련 컨텐츠 제작
등 다양하게 사업을 확장해 나가고
계시는데요 좀 계속해서 새로운 도전을
해 나가시는 이유가 있을까요 일단은
하고 싶은게 너무 많고요 너무 많고
저희가 흔히 아는 그런 부동산
중계업체 뭐 그런 좀을 좀 깨고 싶고
부동산으로 시작하긴 했지만 그와
관련된 일은 모두 다 해봐야 된다라고
저는 생각은 하거든요 그래서 남들이
막 비웃고 뭐 그럴 수도 있지만
어디서 어떻게 될지
모르거든요네 저는 앞으로도이 부동산과
관련된 일은 뭐 이것저것 다 할
생각이고 그리고 사업이라는게 뭐 제가
그렇게 많이 해보진 않았지만 영원한
건 없어요음 네네 영원한 건 없고
그리고 안전한 뭔가 사업를 하는게
되게 중요하다라고 보거든요음네 그
사실 작년 같은 경우에는 빌딩 시장이
좋지 않았는데 만약에 제가 뭐 빌딩
매매 중계만 하고 있으면 그냥 다 손
빨고 있어야
되거든요 맞 근데 좀 안정적인 사업을
계속 이렇게 좀 만들어 놓으면은
다른게 이제 시장이 안 좋아졌을 때
이거 가지고 이제 좀 유지하고
그러거든요 이런 시대와 맞게 좀
변화도 계속 해야 된다라고 저는
생각을 합니다 아 네기가
요 앞선 질문과 좀 이어지는 질문일
것 같은데네 물론 도전을 응원해
주시는 분들도 계실 테지만 또 그러다
다 놓칠 수도 있지 않을까 이런 하는
걱정과 염려의 말씀을 해 주시는
분들도 계실 거 같아요 네네 또
아무래도 많은 파트너분들과 함께
하시다 보니까 어깨도 좀 무거우실 것
같고네 그렇다면 그룹의 리더로서 갖고
계신 신념이나네
혹은 또 이루고 싶은 목표가 있다면
어떤게 있으실지 궁금합니다 일단은
본업은 무조건 잘해야 되고 그까 제가
말씀드린 그런 새로운 도전은 이걸
버리고 새로운 걸 한다 그게 아니라
일단 본업은 본업대로 잘하고 거기
플러스에 새로운 걸
붙이자라는 얘기고요 그리고 어 저는
아 이거 좀 하고 싶다라고 하면
웬만하면 다 해보고 선택하는
편이에요네 그니까지 같 경우에도 작년
말에 생각했던 거거든요 진짜 몇 개월
만에 뚝딱 나왔고네 맞아요 그래서이
모든게 지금 bsn 모든게 다 그냥
일단 해보자 하고 시작한 다음에 좀
일들이 일어났어요 그래서네 저는
앞으로도 좀 이렇게 새로운 것들을 좀
찾아서 무조건
하자라는 식에 좀 도전을 할 거고
그리고 저는 이루고 싶은 목표는
우리나라에서 시작을 했지만 저는 이제
해외에서 성공하고
싶거든요음네 그고 하고 싶은게 되게
많은데 다 얘기해도 되나 이거 시간이
많이 걸 텐데 아무튼
그렇습니다네네 벌써 마지막
질문인데요네 강남에는 정말 많은
중개법인이 있는데요 아 그죠
고객분들께서 bsn 찾아 주시는
이유는 뭐라고
생각하시는지 아직 bsn 인연을 맺지
못하신 예비
고객분들께네 bsn 어필할 기회를
드리겠습니다 어로 정의하자면 좀
신뢰라는 단어랑 맞는 거 같아요네
그래서 제가 되게 추구하고 싶었던 그
회사의 이미지 고객한테 무조건 신뢰를
주자라는 사명으로 좀 했는데
고객분들이 좀 그것를 좀 많이 알아
주시는 거 같고네 그리고 저희가 다른
중개법인이 좀 다른 점은 일단 첫
번째로 중개사에 다 빌딩과 관련된
일들을 다 해요 사실 건축사 사무소
그 건설업체를 하는게 사실 쉽지않
그냥 소개가 아니라 직접해준다는 거
자체가 그냥 그걸 다 책임지겠다는
거거든요네 아마 다른 업체을 조금
다른 점이 좀 그런 부분에 있지
않을까 진짜 다 책임지 애네 그리고
나중에 이제 임대도 맞춰주고 나중에
팔아 주기까지 그런 부분에서는 좀
다른 중개법인이 좀 다르다고 저는
생각을
합니다네네
감사합니다 건물 투자하시는 분들은
bsn 오시면 될 것 같습니다 오늘은
김윤수 대표님과 함께했는데요 보시는
분들께 즐겁고 유익한 시간이었길
바라면서 여기서 마치겠습니다
감사합니다 감사합니다
[음악]